Patt 40 from Yahoo Sports national
college columnist joining us what do you
make of what urban put out late Friday
afternoon I thought it's pretty brazen
Dan really did you know it was I I dub
that protect urban Friday he is his
statement and then seemingly very much
coordinated with Zack Smith doing
multiple interviews and saying that you
know urban would never have tolerated
him if he had he hit Courtney Smith you
know I to me for a guy that is on paid
administrative leave that his actions
are under investigation to come out with
this statement which was extremely
self-centered it was all about urban I
thought that it was pretty remarkable
and it also basically subtly shifted
blame like any I guess seven million
dollar middle management employee would
do to to his superiors part of the blame
necessarily but responsibility part of
Pat's column he wrote if you missed the
column over the weekend seemingly on
thin ice Urban Meyer's skated out to the
middle of the pond Friday and declared
that he can walk on water
your move Ohio State what is Ohio
State's next move well you know they've
commissioned this this panel to look
into it and it's pretty high-powered
Commission you know woman leading it has
has dealt with some very high-profile
contentious public sports related
disputes whether it's Jerry Richardson
and Carolina Ezekiel Elliott and Dallas
so I don't think that you know that
they've exactly appointed a rubber-stamp
sort of committee or a bunch of people
who have been who will be easily cowed
by the the profile of this thing so
we'll see what happens with that
obviously the one other person we
haven't heard anything from is Jean
Smith the entire director and maybe
because he's doing water but I thought
herbin would and should do which is just
be quiet let this thing play out but a
lot of questions obviously for Jean
Smith the athletic director as well I'm
right with you I thought this would go
quiet it would go silent and her
wouldn't say anything and it would sort
of like let's just let's let other
people move on to other things and then
we can circle the wagons here and trying
to figure this out
but it felt like urban was saying I did
everything I was supposed to do except
for lying in the press conference where
I was I was ill-prepared
and now I remember now hey basically
check with the other higher-ups at Ohio
State yeah exactly I mean that that was
pretty remarkable to me is like oh yeah
you know when I apologize because I
wasn't quite ready for those questions
about the position coach we just fired
even though any intelligent coach and
Urban Meyer's surely an intelligent
coach would figure those questions would
be coming at media day so I'm not quite
buying the I wasn't prepared blind from
him on that you know it was again the
whole thing I very surprising to me and
if I were you know in Ohio State's
administration I at least didn't say in
urban what the heck are you doing here I
mean you you just kind of drawn a line
and and made this a much more kind of
contentious OUTFRONT situation I don't
know if it was one of those let me have
a legal backdrop here or at least a
legal guardian angel just in case I get
fired I'm letting you know I'm gonna get
my money here do you think that factored
in at all with this statement that he
put out on Friday I mean it does kind of
seem like it you know that he made made
it clear publicly wanted to that he went
through proper protocol and procedures
whatever that may be he didn't explain
it but that's what he said he did so
that you know was was basically a hey I
did my job and if you want to fire me
you're gonna owe me 38 million here
because you're not gonna fire me for
cause you know whether that was the sole
reasoning here I don't know but I think
it could certainly dovetail with any
other need that he felt to uh to you
know quote unquote clear his name
knowing what you know does he survive
this boy I I don't feel like I know
enough okay but my guest Dan is you just
might as a gut feel as yes he does
you know I think that
again I there's so many questions we
still don't have answers to why did they
keep him for three years sex myth on
staff after this was it solely Urban's
idea was Gene Smith involved in that
decision was anybody else involved with
that information I have a better sense I
guess of where I think this panel could
go with it but just my gut feel which is
based on more than gut is that yes he's
still going to be the coach at Ohio
State now you know is there some
disciplinary action there could be but I
have a feeling he will still be coaching
Ohio State how do you prove that you
sent this up the the corporate ladder
here at Ohio State and you gave them all
the information you did everything you
were supposed to do if there are no
emails no text messages how do you prove
that or disprove that yeah I don't know
it's a very good question you know other
than obviously if Zack Smith says and if
Zack Smith is trustworthy
I don't know how trustworthy he was I
thought he did a pretty terrible job in
his interviews but I would imagine he
didn't lie about being called off the
road recruiting and sitting down with
Gene Smith now whether that's because
urban facilitated and said hey this is
going on gene you need to know or not
that at least so it would the fact that
there was that meeting I think somewhat
takes the the onus off of urban and says
okay my boss was involved in this but
you know again they there there's
there's a whole bunch of more
documentation and other things I would
love to be did that for there to be
available to figure this thing out I'm
just surprised he kept how good is Zack
Smith I know that there's this
allegiance to Earle brutes you know but
but why are you keeping me on your staff
that's a huge question all this you know
there's I think there's one of three
explanations or maybe some combination
of three it's a yes if there's just this
absolute staunch loyalty to Earl Bruce
that you're willing to put up with
repeat headaches at Florida and at Ohio
State you know at the very least
headaches at worse they're they're far
worse than that there's you know you're
putting up with domestic assault too
there was the text message of Brent
McMurphy reported
about zachsmith saying he could take
down Ohio State and whether that's empty
threats or not I don't know and then
three you know the other thing here that
I kind of wonder whether it's in play is
was Urban Meyer kind of swallowing his
own mythology here and believing you
know I'm Urban Meyer we don't make
mistakes
we don't you know we don't do the wrong
thing and if there's some of that shades
of the Paterno era of our program is so
pristine and so perfect that we don't we
don't have it mistakes and so we're just
not going to acknowledge that there
might have been a mistake
anything else going on in college
football Penn completely taken over
August so far I mean the the one of the
preseason top 25 s came out and I don't
make anybody even notices because
everybody's waiting to see whether bin'
Meyer still couldn't be the coach of a
top five team are they atop five if he
loses his job no no I mean we're talking
about you know as I said one of the most
accomplished coaches and a very powerful
figure I don't think you throw this over
to Ryan day and say okay go win the Big
Ten especially when I think it's going
to be a pretty darn competitive Big Ten
this year they're there they're probably
still the most talented team in the Big
Ten but I can't see them winning it
being a top five team without Urban
Meyer good stuff Pat thank you we
appreciate your time Pat forty Yahoo
Sports National College columnist for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Dan Patrick show app
[Music]